[Musique]
le 4 février 2020 alors qu'il fait son
entrée au congrès pour le traditionnel
discours sur l'état de l'union le
président des états unis est sous le
coup d'une mise en accusation pour abus
de pouvoir le discours sur l'état de
l'union était un moment surréaliste ce
qu'on aurait dit de la télé réalité
un peu comme un jeu télévisé donald
trump jubile sous les acclamations de
ses fidèles partisans et il affiche un
mépris ostensible pour ceux qu'il
considère comme ses adversaires
c'est la première fois que je voyais un
tel niveau de division
lors du discours sur l'état de l'union
[Applaudissements]
le discours de trump est ponctuée par
les applaudissements du corps
républicain sur les bancs des démocrates
c'est le silence le plus absolu il n'y
avait aucune adresse à la nation il n'y
avait qu'un message pour ses plus
fidèles partisans présents dans la salle
en over the beast et j ai tkm
jamais le fossé entre le camp du
président et son opposition n'a été
aussi profond jamais la haine politique
ne s'est affichée en public avec une
telle virulence c'est une métaphore de
notre époque troublée alors que pour
faire face à la pandémie qui menace le
monde
l'amérique a besoin d'un pouvoir unis
jamais les institutions de la démocratie
américaine n'ont semblé si divisée nous
sommes en train de vivre une période
très difficile pour les états unis
comment en est on arrivé là
voici l'histoire de près de 200 jours de
l'une des batailles politiques les plus
violentes de toute l'histoire des états
unis
[Musique]
l'ambiance était beaucoup moins tendue
six mois plus tôt en juillet 2019 au
congrès au moment où l'investigation qui
avait jusque-là hanter la présidence de
trump touchait à sa fin
le procureur spécial robert muller qui
avait mené l'enquêté sur les soupçons de
collusions entre trump et les russes
lors de l'élection présidentielle de
2016 c'est est venu témoigner devant le
congrès le procureur muller a répété les
principales conclusions de son enquête à
savoir que les russes ont bien
interférer dans la campagne de 2016 qui
apporte des preuves au pouvoir et que
selon lui il continue de manipuler le
processus électoral américain
mais l'implication de trump lui même n'a
jamais pu être démontré formellement
pour trump la prudence de müller revient
à le blanchir complètement le président
semble savourer sa victoire
mais l'accalmie dans cette bataille qui
dure depuis le début de son mandat sera
de courte durée
[Musique]
à la fin de l'été dans la capitale
fédérale
on se remet au travail à nouveau donald
trump en d'autres pleinement son costume
de président des états unis
c'est alors que politico un journal très
influent dans le microcosme de la
capitale américaine sort une information
apparemment anodine
on a reçu un tuyau de plusieurs de nos
sources qui indiquait que certains
industriels américains avaient eu vent
de la suspension de l'aide militaire à
l'ukraine
un pays lointain que la plupart des
américains seraient bien incapables de
situer sur une carte les gens qui
s'intéressent à la politique et aux
affaires étrangères ici aux etats unis
savent que l'ukraine est en conflit avec
la russie que la russie a pris la crimée
à l'ukraine que la russie a envahi la
partie orientale de l'ukraine en y
envoyant des troupes et que les
ukrainiens sont littéralement en guerre
avec les forces russes en ukraine un
nouveau président vladimir zelensky
vient tout juste d'être élu mais a
besoin d'appui face à la menace de son
puissant voisin
la russie techniquement l'ukraine n'est
pas un allié des états unis n'avons
aucun accord de sécurité avec eux mais
nous avons donné des assurances
politiques après leur indépendance
je pense que ça veut dire quelque chose
je pense que l'indépendance et
l'intégrité territoriale de tous pays
devrait signifier quelque chose pour
tous les américains
mais quand parce que si ces valeurs sont
enfreintes alors qui est vraiment au
sécurité y est c'est trump supprime une
aide militaire crucial pour l'ukraine
qui est en guerre contre la russie et
pour les russes c'est la principale zone
de conflit dans cette région à l'époque
très peu de gens à washington se doute
que la suspension de l'aide militaire à
l'ukraine est sur le point de provoquer
le scandale le plus retentissant de la
présidence trucks
au début on a cru que c'était encore les
nombreux scandales venant de
l'administration trump si vous aviez dit
aux américains qu'un scandale sur l'aide
militaire à l'ukraine entraînerait la
destitution d'un président personne
n'aurait misé un kopeck là dessus
en réaction au scoop publié par le
journal politico la maison blanche des
blocs en urgence les militaires à
l'ukraine l'information est brièvement
mentionné dans un journal spécialisé
dans la défense
au lendemain de cette publication le
président ne semble pas le moins du
monde
inquiet il préside les cérémonies de
commémoration du 11-septembre
ouais
un court moment empreint de dignité
le calme avant la tempête qui
s'apprêtait à éclater
suite aux atermoiements de la maison
blanche sur la question de l'aide
militaire m cren
[Musique]
et tout ça ne semblait pas très grave
jusqu'à ce que le signalement du lanceur
d'alert sortent au grand jour
la presse parle d'un signalement venant
d'un lanceur d' alerte à l'intérieur
même de l'administration américaine
un lanceur d' alerte est un
fonctionnaire témoin d'un acteur
répréhensible et qu'ils le signalent
selon une procédure très réglementé le
lanceur d'alert décrit explicitement un
appel téléphonique entre trump et le
président et lenski le 25 juillet comme
pour toutes les conversations
téléphoniques officielle un certain
nombre de conseillers des deux côtés
écoute l'entretien
du côté américain ses conseillers
appartiennent à différentes
administrations pentagone équivalent du
ministère de la défense
le département d'état autrement dit les
affaires étrangères et la cia les
services secrets américains vous aviez
donc quelqu'un des renseignements qui a
été mis au courant de cet appel avec le
président ukrainien qui a inquiété
ceux qui en ont une connaissance
président agissait sans apparemment se
soucier de l'intérêt national américain
je peux seulement vous dire qu'il a été
rapporté dans la presse que c'était un
membre de la cia est logiquement on peut
se demander mais comment cette personne
est elle au courant lorsque cette
personne révèle l'information
il ya une procédure de vérification qui
garantit sa crédibilité qui garantit que
ce n'est pas une accusation en l'air
inventé par quelqu'un et ça la plainte
du lanceur d'alerté est avalisée par
plusieurs responsables des services
secrets
[Musique]
la loi prévoit qu'elle soit présenté au
président de la commission parlementaire
du renseignement
adachi
[Musique]
lacroix chaise la question est la
suivante
existe-t-il un précédent ou un lanceur
d'alert dénonce le président des états
unis
la réponse est non bien sûr
l'administration trump voulait éviter ça
alors que s'est-il passé
le procureur général william barre l'un
des principaux protecteurs de donald
trump tout au long de cette affaire a
obtenu du ministère de la justice
un arrêté selon lequel ce signalement
particulier au contraire des autres
signalements de lancer des alertes ne
devait pas aboutir devant le parlement
des soins de dena donc le député adam
schiff a envoyé une lettre rendue
publique ce qui expliqué qu'ils avaient
été informés de la plainte d'un lanceur
d' alerte et qu'il ne savait pas du tout
de quoi il s'agissait
à washington ce qui doit rester secret
ne le reste jamais longtemps
profil des dîners dans les bars et les
restaurants l'information circule elle
passe des fonctionnaires aux
journalistes
et bientôt l'ukraine devient le nouveau
scandale qui aiguise la curiosité et
limite les fantasmes de millions
d'américains
le mot youpine gates fait son apparition
dans le jargon politique
il remplace le watergate le scandale qui
avait marqué la première partie du
mandat 30
la presse révèle que trump a demandé à
son homologue ukrainien d'enquêter sur
joe biden l'ex vice président démocrate
qui est son principal rival pour les
futures élections et sur son fils hunter
binder qui travaillait pour une
entreprise l'ukrainienne nommé bourhis
ma en échange de ses informations
l'ukrainien zelensky se seraient vus
promettre l'aide militaire américaine et
le soutien de tron le président
s'apprête à s'envoler pour siéger à
l'assemblée annuelle des nations unies à
new york
mais c'est sa conversation téléphonique
avec zelensky qui occupe tous les
commentaires
[Musique]
hu pour trump et ses partisans
l'entretien d'exellence qui n'était
qu'un banal échange entre chefs d'état
nous disons toujours débarrassez vous de
la corruption sinon vous n'obtiendrez
pas d'elle c'était pas un problème qui
ne pensaient pas que c'en était un
bazin d'ukrainiens considéré que c'en
était un politico a dit que ça pourrait
en être un et les démocrates ont dit oh
c'est un problème grave mais en dépit de
ces dénégations trump a commis une
erreur et ses adversaires vont
rapidement en profiter le congrès avait
affecté des fonds pour envoyer des armes
en ukraine et légalement une fois que le
congrès a obtenu ces fontes la
possibilité pour qui que ce soit de
retenir ces fonds est très étroitement
limité le gouvernement ne peut pas se
contenter de dire qu'au nom de la
politique étrangère nous ne voulons pas
donner cet argent et s'ils veulent
suspendre une aide
ils doivent l'annoncé et l'expliquer et
ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé ce que
les démocrates ont fait valoir
et en fait c'est qu'un certain nombre de
parlementaires des deux partis ont fait
valoir
c'est que cela violait la loi la loi
était donc empreintes et par conséquent
l'équilibré des pouvoirs entre le
président et le pouvoir législatif était
bouleversée à peine 2
[Musique]
washington est désormais le théâtre d'un
nouvel affrontement à face à face d'une
violence inédite et si l'opinion
américaine se passionne soudain pour ce
duel politique sans précédent
c'est parce que cette fois c'est une
femme qui mène l'offensive contre donald
trump
elle s'appelle nancy pelosi et c'est la
première femme de l'histoire à occuper
le poste de président de la chambre des
représentants va lancer une enquête de
destitution qui pourrait annuler les
résultats d'une élection quoique c'est
un véritable séisme
jusqu'ici seuls trois présidents des
états unis ont été sous le coup d'une
mise en accusation visant à les
destituer andrew johnson richard nixon
et bill clinton pour aucun d'entre eux
la procédure de destitution est allée à
son terme
[Musique]
jobin
la décision de mettre en accusation
donald trump constitue larmes la plus
fatale dans l'arsenal dont dispose même
si pelosi
[Musique]
l'enquêté lancée par la chambre des
représentants contrôlée par les
démocrates
depuis novembre 2018 c'est cette
assemblée qui établit les chefs
d'accusation et qui votent les article
stipulant les crimes dont le président
est accusé
ces articles sont ensuite présentés à
l'autre chambre le sénat
transformée en tribunal qui votent pour
ou contre la destitution du président
mais le sénat est contrôlé par les
républicains
ils ont une majorité écrasante à même de
bloquer tout destitution et même si
pelosi en est parfaitement consciente
selon la constitution il faut un vote
des deux tiers au sénat soit 67
sénateurs sur 100 il y avait cinquante
trois sénateurs républicains à l'époque
et c'est toujours le cas
il aurait donc fallu vingt sénateurs
républicains et tous les démocrates
votant pour la condamnation
nancy pelosi n'a jamais eu l'illusion
qu'il y aurait une condamnation et un
renvoi de la maison blanche
alors pourquoi cette procédure sans
avenir pour nancy pelosi
il s'agit de démontrer que trump est
inapte à exercer la fonction de
président des états unis
en quête d'un trimestre jusqu'à ce jour
nancy pelosi a toujours été réticente à
mettre le président trump en accusation
en 2018 au moment de l' enquête sur
l'ingérence russe elles y étaient
fermement opposés
alors pourquoi l'ukraine qui pour
beaucoup de gens semblent plus
insignifiante que la question de
l'ingérence russe au profit de celui qui
a gagné l'élection
pourquoi l'ukraine la ferait elle changé
d'avis sur cette question cruciale de la
destitution fortement tout d'abord lé
enquête de robert müller était très
complexe
en revanche le scandale ukrainien je
pense est un récit beaucoup plus simple
et qui frappe plus fort les esprits
matches c'est beaucoup plus facile à
décrire en une minute sur les chaînes
d'information d'accueil enquête miller
le président des états unis a clairement
abusé de son pouvoir en demandant un
président dans notre pays et de
s'ingérer dans une élection à chaîne en
son nom le message de nancy pelosi et si
ça ce n'est pas un motif de destitution
alors qu'est ce qui le serait quelques
mois avant les élections de novembre
2020 le pari est tentant pour les
démocrates
l'anc est à mettre en lumière les
débordements du président l'opinion
publique sera prise à témoin et les
électeurs indécis seront convaincus
qu'ils doivent se mobiliser pour priver
trump d'un second mandat
le jeu en vaut la chandelle
[Musique]
la confrontation judiciaire qui vient de
commencer va ébranler pendant des mois
l'ensemble de l'administration
américaine la maison blanche siège du
pouvoir exécutif
[Musique]
le congrès qui est censée contrôler les
agissements du président la cia d'où est
partie la laërt le pentagone dont le
programme d'eads militaire a été mise en
cause
[Musique]
et enfin le département d'état chargé
des affaires étrangères
la décision de nancy pelosi de lancer la
procédure de destitution contre trump
rattrape le président alors qu'il siège
à l'assemblée générale des nations unies
à new york
il profite de l'occasion pour organiser
une conférence de presse conjointe avec
son homologue zelensky une tribune
idéale pour répondre aux accusations
aient attaqué celle qui l'accablent
[Musique]
au même moment à washington la maison
blanche contre attaque
on reproche à trump son coup de fil à
zelensky qu'à cela ne tienne la
présidence des sites révélé cet élément
central de la controverse ukrainienne la
conversation téléphonique du 25 juillet
2019 entre les deux présidents et rendu
public le plus incroyable dans cette
histoire c'est que le coup de fil entre
le président tron et le président céline
ce qui s'est produit le lendemain de la
déposition de robert müller donc je
pense que beaucoup d'entre nous ont cru
que le président venait d'entendre cette
déposition et qu'il s'était peut-être
calmer et qu'il ferait preuve de plus de
prudence désormais mais qu'est-ce qu'il
fait le contraire le lendemain il
décroche son téléphone et on a
l'impression qu'il s'est dit que j'ai
été blanchi maintenant je peux faire ce
que je veux
[Musique]
les services de la maison blanche rendre
public un compte rendu du coup de fil sa
publication est censé innocenté le
président de toute faute dans la
suspension de l'aide militaire à
l'ukraine
ce qui a attiré l'attention des gens
c'est elle est partie de la conversation
où le président a dit je suis prêt à
débloquer cette aide si vous êtes prêt à
me faire une faveur
donald trump renoncer modem du célèbre
toutefois j'aimerais que vous nous
fassiez au kent rusé enquêter sur les
baleines il semblait donc clair qu'il y
avait une contrepartie le président a
demandé à une puissance étrangère de
trouver des renseignements
compromettants sur un rival politique et
qui à l'époque était en tête dans les
sondages loin de disculper le président
la publication de la conversation
téléphonique entre trump et zelensky est
considéré comme extrêmement
compromettantes
j'ai lu cette transcription je suis
resté bouche bée en tant qu ancien
procureur je me suis dit je n'arrive pas
à croire ce que donald kohn dit dans
cette construction et je ne peux pas
croire que la maison blanche
les publier les présidents américains
n'ont pas pour habitude d'exiger des
faveurs de dirigeants étrangers
sollicité l'intervention d'un chef
d'état étranger pour son propre maintien
au pouvoir
bernès c'est sans précédent à notre
époque c'est certain et il est très
clair que rien de tout cela n'était dans
l'intérêt de la sécurité nationale des
états unis
mais bien dans l'intérêt personnel et
politique du président dès que le coup
de fil et rendu public le camp de donald
trump se retrouve sur la défensive
j'ai lu tout le contenu plusieurs fois
en tant qu ancien procureur je ne voyais
pas en quoi
que diriez vous de nous rendre service
avec quoi que ce soit à voir avec une
suspension de l'aide
la volonté du président entre up
c'était de mettre fin à la corruption
d'ukraine on est médecin qu'il était
logique qu'il fasse attention à ne pas
donner l'argent à un oligarque qui leur
est dépensé ont mis sur un compte
bancaire en suisse personne impartiale
odette lisant cette transcription ne
peut-il trouver quoi que ce soit à
redire
[Musique]
quid pro quo au congrès l'investigation
contre le président va bon train
les démocrates ne se satisfont pas des
dénégations de trump et il escompte bien
partager leurs doutes avec l'opinion
américaine
les premières auditions la chambre des
représentants se font à huis clos alors
les républicains accusent les démocrates
de tenir secret leur manoeuvre pour
discréditer le président
c'était fou parce que les républicains
étaient en fait présent pour chacune des
auditions organisées par les démocrates
environ 48 républicains étaient
autorisés à participer à ces audiences à
huis clos
donc l'argument s'est rapidement
effondré
pour couper court à ces accusations mme
nancy pelosi décide de lever le voile
et elle demande à la chambre d'autoriser
les auditions publiques
tu des deux bords superbe deux steaks
hachés steak and death is nothing has
den haag mars et la résolution de rendre
publics les auditions du congrès est
adoptée des millions d'américains vont
pouvoir suivre le grand déballage en
direct cette fois le spectacle tout
commence
[Musique]
la perspective des auditions publiques
met en rage le président entre eux il ne
supporte pas l'idée d'avoir à
s'expliquer publiquement
nous sommes convaincus que les
journalistes et les démocrates sont
ligués contre lui pour l'éjecter de la
maison blanche
trump se rallier le soutien de sa base
et lancent des attaques au vitriol
contre ses adversaires
[Applaudissements]
crise ou pas
résine et ses résines et crazy
le chef tichy haf abad de sky a battu
l'objet des sarcasmes et du mépris de
trump s'appelle adam schiff
il est élu démocrate et préside la
puissante commission du renseignement à
la chambre des représentants alem
chiffres c'est un ancien procureur c'est
un élu de la banlieue de los angeles
il a la confiance de nancy pelosi parce
qu'il est d'une grande probité
intellectuelle
il parle bien en public et en tant que
procureur il sait faire la synthèse des
faits
j'ai pu constater tout au long de la
procédure son expérience de procureur
fédéral
il a recherché les preuves avec
détermination et obstination et voulait
à tout prix trouver la vérité quelle que
soit la difficulté en novembre
commission chiffres entendent 12 témoin
il s'agit de diplomates de
fonctionnaires et de militaires
il témoigne sous serment
en cas de faux témoignages il risque la
prison
au centre des auditions la désormais
fameuse conversation entre trump et le
président ukrainien wladimir zelensky la
première à témoigner s'appelle maria
yovanovitch c'est l'ancienne
ambassadrice des états unis en ukraine
et elle a été rappelée à washington en
parlant d'elle au téléphone trump a dit
à zellik ski qu'elle était une pas de
news
en d'autres termes une gêne deux
[Musique]
chantent
le témoin suivant est un modèle de
parfaits américain c'est le colonel
wiedemann un immigré venu d'ukraine qui
a gravi un à un les échelons de la
hiérarchie militaire pour devenir
conseiller à la maison blanche
il fait partie de ceux qui ont pu
écouter la conversation téléphonique du
25 juillet entre trump et zelensky
puis c'est au tour de gordon sunrise un
homme d'affaires proche de trump qui a
été ambassadeur des états unis auprès de
l'union européenne à bruxelles son land
explique dans l'entourage du président
l'homme en charge des questions du
craignent elle n'est autre que l'ancien
maire de new york rudy giuliani le
conseiller le plus proche de donald
trump
c'est lui qui a imaginé conclure un
marché donnant donnant avec le président
hélène ce qui les services ukrainiens
font une enquête à charge sur bayonne
père et fils en échange de l'aide
militaire et du soutien de trump et
someone ajoute que toute la haute
administration et donald trump lui même
était tout à fait au courant de la
diplomatie parallèle menées par giuliani
enfin une experte des questions russes
conclut le défilé des témoins fiona il a
travaillé à la maison blanche
et elle donne finalement la clé de
lecture de cette énigme où se mêlent
l'ukraine la russie et la politique
américaine
elle conteste la version de prob et
giuliani sur la fère ukrainienne adam
schiff claude ses auditions bien
conscient que les faits qui ont émergé
ont dressé un portrait très inquiétant
du jeu politique aux etats unis
[Musique]
tandis qu'au congrès la commission chief
accumulait les preuves contre trump ce
dernier a préféré fuir le marigot de la
capitale il sillonne le pays à la
rencontre de ces supporters auprès d'eux
ils se sentent en sécurité et partage sa
fureur avec les foules en délire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
and waste vote
owen jones s'est même mis feu à un dépôt
légal et que je suis appelé je pense un
vrai parisien
l'objectif de trump dans ce combat pour
sa vérité c'est la conquête de l'opinion
américaine
un an avant l'élection présidentielle
trump c'est que l'amérique profonde ne
se soucie guère de l'ukraine gate et que
la base de son électorat lui restera
fidèle mais toute une frange de
l'opinion semble avoir doucement glissé
dans le camp des partisans de la
poursuite de l'enquêté
[Musique]
les sondages sont clairs et ils montrent
que depuis le début des auditions au
congrès une majorité d'américains est
passé du côté de la mise en accusation
au congrès après le sensationnel défilé
des témoins la procédure de destitution
entre dans une phase beaucoup moins
spectaculaire c'est la commission
judiciaire qui prend le relais présidée
par gérald nadler c'est elle qui rédige
des articles de mise en accusation
basé sur le résultat des auditions
publiques on va enfin connaître
l'intitulé des crimes que l'on reproche
au président john f
alors que les démocrates sont focalisés
sur le processus judiciaire qui apparaît
comme un peu laborieux trump lui
sacrifier la tradition de noël qui
approche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il n'y a pas de trêve de noël dans
la bataille qui agite washington les
actes d'accusation soumises au vote à la
chambre des représentants sans surprise
l'assemblée dominée par les démocrates
vote pour la destitution nancy pelosi a
du mal à cacher sa joie
quoi qu'il arrive désormais elle restera
comme la femme qui aura obtenu la mise
en accusation formelle du président des
états unis
comme à chaque fois qu'il perd le
contrôle des événements politiques à
washington
trump s'en retourne vers ses supporters
aux quatre coins du pays
comme toujours il évite de répondre aux
accusations et cherche à discréditer le
processus judiciaire qui le frappe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
le groupe de gens formidables dont parle
donald trump
ce sont les sénateurs républicains ce
sont eux qui vont procéder à l'examen
final des articles de mise en accusation
le 15 janvier 2020 soit un mois après le
vote de la chambre
les chefs d'accusation sont transférés
au sénat la loi américaine veut que pour
juger le président la chambre haute se
transforme en une cour de justice
c'est là que sera mené le procès final
dont l'issue sera l'acquittement ou la
destitution du président mais ce procès
tant attendu se transforme bien vite en
parodie de justice après le vote de la
chambre la mise en accusation a été
transféré au sénat qui a ouvert un
procès je pense que le mot procès n'est
vraiment pas adéquat un procès sans
présentation de preuves et sans témoins
des phases un procès c'est comme une
tartine de confiture sans confiture ça
le sénat conduite des procès en
destitution non seulement pour les
présidents mais aussi pour les juges
fédéraux et dans chacun des procès menés
par le sénat depuis les origines jusqu'à
nos jours il ya eu des témoins même
quand le président ne voulait pas la
chambre des représentants a eu la
possibilité de convoquer autant de
témoin qu'elle le voulait il pouvait
prendre tout leur temps en fait il
voulait que le sénat convoque des
témoins pour faire ce qu'il n'avait pas
fait ils ont fait un travail lamentables
ils ont monté une accusation
complètement bidon et le sénat l'a bien
vu et ya mis fin
lorsque les sénateurs ont décidé après
délibération de ne pas convoquer de
témoin alors il est devenu clair que
l'emprise politique de donald trump sur
le parti républicain était totale
et voici enfin venu le jour de gloire
pour tron la veille du verdict du sénat
c'est un président assuré de l'absolue
loyauté des siens au congrès s'apprête à
lire le traditionnel discours solennel
sur l'état de l'union
la situation est complètement inédite
dans toute l'histoire des états unis
c'est la première fois qu'un président
mise en examen pour abus de pouvoir
s'adresse à la nation
un président qui plus est en campagne
pour sa réélection
la grande salle du congrès se transforme
en meeting électoral
le discours sur l'état de l'union a été
un moment surréaliste
nous venions d'être bombardée pendant
des mois d'information et de fait sur la
corruption du président et le voilà qui
prononce le discours et ils ont fait
comme à son habitude une célébration de
sa propre victoire d'une certaine
manière on a l'impression que ces
occasions solennelles tourner au
rassemblement politique
au lieu d'être un événement national qui
rapproche les parties le président tron
va transformer l'état de l'union en en
jeu télévisé où il y aurait une voiture
à gagner pour chaque nouvel électeur
politique qui le soutiendraient jérôme g
jona
sow
six nations
[Applaudissements]
9h20
se servir des hommes et des femmes en
uniforme à tout pour démontrer à quel
point notre chef bien aimé est noble et
sans faille et complètement anti
américain
[Applaudissements]
le discours de trump est un spectacle
millimétré
une véritable performance d'acteur au
milieu de laquelle il fait une fugace
allusion à un problème sanitaire qui
semble-t-il n'entame en rien l'euphorie
de sa victoire à venir
[Applaudissements]
m
ce moment incroyable où le troisième
personnage de l'état déchire le discours
du président à la tribune résume à lui
tout seul la tension extrême qui a
complètement gangrené les structures du
pouvoir à washington depuis des mois
je
wade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout au long de son mandat
donald trump a menti aux américains
régulièrement et de manière répétée et
sans scrupules
est ce que le président trump un
problème avec la vérité oui il un
problème avec la vérité
cela fait longtemps que j'ai des
inquiétudes concernant sa manière de
gouverner son manque de netteté absolue
sur n'importe quel jour de la semaine
si vous prenez un journal qui vérifie
les faits vous voyez que ses mensonges
après mensonge après mon sens ce qu'il a
appris de son expérience à la télévision
avant de devenir président c'est que si
vous répéter sans cesse quelque chose
encore et encore et encore
les gens vont finir par le croire et
nous y sommes devenus indifférents
je ne pense pas que les gens soient
encore surpris quand on découvre qu'il
ment il peut mentir et être surpris en
train de mentir et répété ce même
mensonge le lendemain je pense que le
président trump crois qu'à force de
répéter les choses sans arrêt elles
deviennent vrai
[Musique]
ce meilleur qui reste à venir et que
trump a promis aux américains
c'est en fait la bonne nouvelle qu'ils
attendaient elle interviendra le
lendemain le 5 février le jour de la
session historique du sénat qui met un
point final au processus de destitution
une fois n'est pas coutume les gros
titres des journaux font le bonheur du
président il célèbre son triomphe et
donald trump s'en va fêter sa victoire
avec ses partisans
il affectionne rien tant que de
s'immerger dans les foules qui
l'acclament c'est parmi eux qu'ils
donnent toute la mesure de ses talents
d'homme de spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis pedro de fo un coût allant dans
son discours qui dure pas moins d'une
heure et demie une heure et demie
d'autosatisfaction victorieuse trump se
permet une petite prédiction pour
l'avenir comme il en a le secret
[Applaudissements]
trump connaît désormais le nom de son
adversaire pour la présidentielle de
novembre 2020
non
[Musique]
c'est joe biden celui qui l'attend et de
salies et de disqualifier
[Applaudissements]
l'état l'âge public des agissements de
trump rassembler les démocrates derrière
un candidat modéré en mesure de le
battre
jusqu'ici trump a toujours balayé d'un
revers de la main les obstacles qui se
dressent devant lui mais pour sa
réélection
les bravades les tweets rageur les
diffamations et les mensonges suffiront
ils à venir à bout des embûches qui se
multiplient en travers de la marche
qu'ils espèrent victorieuse
[Musique]
aussi